The first rule in 12 rules for life is stand up straight with your shoulders
back.
And I want to tell you a little bit about the world in which that rule applies.
And it's our world.
But it isn't necessarily the world that you think of when you think of our
world.
Although it's the world,
you know,
it's funny cause it's a world you know,
but you don't know.
You know it.
It's a world that presents itself to you in literary form and in mythological
foreman and symbolic form.
And you all understand it,
but you,
you can't articulate it.
Um,
but I can articulate some of it.
How many of you have seen the lion king?
Okay,
how many of you haven't?
so that's a better question.
Hardly you guys should see the lion king because obviously there's something
wrong with you.
So,
so,
and in any ways,
I want to tell you about the world of the lion king.
Now,
one of the things I want you to notice is that when you go see that movie or
when you show it to your kids,
when you watch it at home,
I don't care what you fall into it.
And that's very strange because first of all,
it's not a world,
it's drawings,
right?
It's animated drawings of a world.
It's very low resolution and the creatures aren't human.
They're animals.
You've all noticed that no doubt.
And the world is magical because things happen in it that aren't the sorts of
things that obviously happened in the real world.
But you don't care about any of that.
You don't care that the animals talk.
You don't care that the lions are kings.
All of that makes perfect sense to you.
And that means that which is a very strange thing,
which it means that the manner in which the characters are represented and the
world that they inhabit is somehow familiar to you because otherwise you
wouldn't fall into it and you wouldn't even.
And you'd notice that what you're doing is so strange because it really is so
strange.
So imagine the opening of the lion king.
So what happens is that the camera pans over the Great African plain and you see
all the animals gathering,
right?
And they're all coming together and there's this kind of thrilling Black Gospel
music going on in the background with an African beat.
And so,
and it's really well done.
The opening of that movie and then the camera pans up like,
like it's revealing something.
And you see this structure that's known in the movie as pride rock.
And so it's this structure that rises up above the plane and it's,
it's shaped like it's a mountain essentially,
although it's not,
it's just a rock,
but it's,
it's a high place.
It's a place that you can,
that you can view everything from.
Right?
So it's a place that,
it's a place from which you can get an overview.
It's a place from which you can see.
And uh,
you're introduced to the king's little bird whose name I don't remember at the
moment,
and he's the eyes of the king.
And so the king is obviously something that has eyes because he has a bird and
the bird can fly around from up above and see everything and report to him.
So whatever the king is is associated with the bird.
Just like Horus,
the ancient Egyptian God was associated with fall,
could in fact for exactly that reason,
fall cans can see better than any other creature by the way,
better even than human beings.
And we have very good eyesight.
So the king is the creature who can see and the king is a lion.
And the reason the lions are king is because the lines at the top of the food
chain.
That's part of it.
But the line is a solar.
Beastie has a main,
he's associated with the sun.
He's associated with the daytime is associated with power and majesty and
strength.
And it's not a mouse that's king,
right?
It's not a rat.
It's,
it's a lion.
And you think,
well obviously the lion is king.
You know,
everyone knows that even though animals don't have kings in case you didn't
notice.
So it's not self evident that it should be the lion.
And the lion is on the rock in the sun,
right?
So the rock sticks up above everything else and the lion is there and the lion
is paternal lion and he has a mate and the scene opens with them giving birth.
And so it's a nativity scene.
And so,
and that's painfully obvious if you watch it with a little bit of detachment,
it's an activity scene and Rafiki who's the Shaman priest lifts up the new
Messiah to the Sun.
And when that happens,
the music swells and all of the animals go down on their knees.
And it's a very,
and then the,
there's a drum beat and the,
the,
the words the lion king come up on stage and it's beautifully done.
It's beautifully done.
They,
they pan up to the revelation of the lion cub to the son two or three times.
And it's really,
it's really emotional moment.
And it's because all of these levels of symbolism lock in at the same time you
have the,
the environment,
the field where all the animals gather.
So all the animals are gathering to review the revelation of something
transcendent and the revelation of what's transcendent is the birth of the new
hero to the king and Queen on the rock above the plane.
And there's a universal truth in that,
which is why the animators worked as hard as they did to make that scene and why
it opens what was one of the most spectacularly successful movies of all time.
And the,
the way the film makers do it is when Rafiq he holds up the,
the infant Simba,
the clouds break and the sun shines on it.
And that's the culminating moment.
And that's the revelation of the identity of the newborn hero with the
consciousness of the sun.
And so we're light creatures.
We're daytime creatures.
We're visual creatures,
right?
We're,
we're not,
we don't,
we're not nocturnal.
The night is when we're unconscious.
The day is when we're conscious and the terminology that we use that's
associated with the furtherance of our consciousness is illumination and
enlightenment.
And so there's a tight relationship between waking up and letting the light
shine in and in consciousness and the association between the rays of the sun
and the lifting up of the infant is the association,
the ancient association between the hero who defeats the forces of darkness and
the Sun itself.
And you all know all of that,
which is why that opening works and why it sets the scene for the rest of the
movie.
And what's the rest of the movie?
Well,
we could think about the landscape.
First of all,
there's a scene where Sam,
his father takes him up on top of pride rock and tells him that his kingdom,
that he's the king and his kingdom extends as far as the light touches.
So the landscape is a place with a pyramid in it.
They're at the top of the pyramid on a plane that's circumscribed by the light
and outside the light is darkness.
And so the,
the mythological landscape in which this story reveals itself is light versus
darkness or order versus chaos.
And the reason for that is because that is our landscape.
We inhabit peer middle structures.
Those are hierarchies of other hierarchies.
I think in our society,
those are mostly hierarchies of competence.
We,
we,
we inhabit hierarchical structures on a plane that's defined,
defined by our understanding,
surrounded by what we do not comprehend,
and that's the universal human world.
And that hierarchy itself is a cooperative structure that enables us to live
with a certain amount of peace and productivity together.
And also to establish a value system with whatever is at the pinnacle of the
hierarchy regarded as whatever's most valuable.
Now think about what happens in the lion king.
It's a,
it's a voyage into what's most valuable.
It's an examination of what's most valuable.